je considère que la famille politique
est belle aussi quand elle protège
c'étaient ceux qui en ont besoin en
l'occurrence le combat des femmes
victimes de violence est un beau combat
pour la france mais aussi pour la droite
républicaine
depuis le 1er janvier nous avons
progressé notamment sur la suspension de
l'autorité parentale
lorsque un mauvais mari n'est pas un bon
père et donc la loi permis d'aller plus
loin sur ces sujets sur l'accès au
téléphone graves dangers sur la
protection du logement pour les victimes
nous hurler brasse garantie
rapprochement et sur les bracelets
anti-rapprochement nous avons beaucoup
de retard et je les dis c'est pour cela
d'ailleurs que j'ai demandé à faire une
mission d'évaluation de la loi ce qui
est assez rare nous devions généraliser
les bracelets anti-rapprochement le
gouvernement devait généralisé au 1er
janvier a été reportée en juin et
aujourd'hui on commence avec 5
expérimentation dans cinq juridictions
du pays avec on l'espère une
généralisation à la fin de l'année et je
le dis très clairement au garde des
sceaux je serai intraitable sur ce sujet
il faut il faut qu'à la fin de l'année
toutes les juridictions du pays et ce
bracelet en dira prochaine cible c'est
aujourd'hui c'est une question de
volonté politique
savez nous sommes dans une période que
je le trouve profondément hypocrite sur
beaucoup de sujets et sûrement sur ce
sujet là aussi qui peut douter qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une volonté politique
partagée quasiment partout sur cette
question là et bien moi je peut en
douter
je peux en douter lorsque je constate
les actes lorsque je vois qu'il ya un
écart monumental entre les paroles et
les actes
les bracelets anti-rapprochement si les
républicains n'avaient pas porté cette
loi on les attendrait toujours ça fait
des années des années de plus que le
gouvernement parle au troc baratine sur
ce sujet savez on se fait plaisir en
portant des pin's en faisant des grandes
déclarations mais le rôle du politique
c'est pas de faire des grandes
déclarations des tweets le rôle du
politique c'est d'agir
moi je suis heureux que par cette loi on
ait pu agir oreilles après nous avons
échoué aux élections présidentielles
nous avons échoué aux élections
européennes
nous reprenons des couleurs avec
christian jacob depuis les élections
municipales notamment mais donc il faut
que nous reconstruisions et nous sommes
en phase de reconstruction
moi je crois que la droite peut porter
un espoir et ça fait quelques années
qu'elle n'a pas porté un espoir et ma
responsabilité y compris celle de ma
génération c'est de le dire mon espoir
c'est que la droite soit capable d'être
ferme sur des questions républicaine et
d'être juste sur les questions ils vont
ils calent sur les questions résidence
et sur les questions de violence
conjugale sur les questions d'écologie
voilà pourquoi j'ai engagé une tour de
france de l'écologie moi je souhaite que
la droite elle porte à nouveau une
espérance pour le pays c'est ça le pire
et politiques auquel je crois pas encore
le choix de l'un ou de l'autre